i've co-founded two yc companies and
learned a lot in the process so here are
nine key takeaways from y combinator
number one start small it can be easy to
focus on big companies that you might be
competing with in the first days of
starting your company but that's a big
mistake big things have small beginnings
every company starts as nothing more
than an idea but what makes big
companies get really really big is that
consistent compounding growth over a
long period of time growth rate is by
far the most important factor in a
startup success it's what every venture
capitalist values most when considering
an investment so you need to start
thinking about growth immediately
focusing on growth rates instead of
absolute numbers can be extremely
motivating this is because the smaller
you are the easier it is to have a high
growth rate if you only have a few
hundred users doubling that number in a
month is completely doable and that will
start compounding pretty quickly as you
get bigger doubling every month might
not be possible but 20 monthly growth is
usually sustainable for companies with
strong product market fit and 20 monthly
growth actually works out to a 10x
increase over a single year i've
personally seen this with my youtube
channel the number of subscribers is
still really small but i've been growing
the channel 20 per month on a very
consistent basis which is extremely
promising so if you're watching this and
you're not subscribed please do me a
favor and help me keep that growth going
y combinator is just three months long
and many enter the program with just an
idea or basic prototype without fail the
companies that get the most attention at
demo day have the highest growth rates
it's way better to be a company that
went from making one thousand dollars at
the start of the program to ten thousand
dollars in just three months then be a
company making a million dollars without
any growth if you're ever feeling like
you're in a david versus goliath
situation going up against massive
competitors just compare your growth
rates the biggest companies in the world
aren't growing 10x in a year but you can
if you build a great product that people
love and that brings me to lesson number
two get into build mode no job or
college degree can ever fully prepare
you for being the founder of a startup
they're all just a little bit too
specialized building a company from
scratch requires bringing together so
many different skills and this is one of
the hardest but also the most rewarding
aspects of entrepreneurship paul graham
says that if you want to start a startup
it's good to know about multiple
unrelated things startups often depend
on four or five different kinds of
knowledge and it's great if they can all
be found in just two founders it's rare
to start your company already knowing
about all the relevant disciplines
required to succeed though so that's why
it's so important to get into build mode
when i say build mode i mean being
willing to roll up your sleeves and
learn the relevant skills to accomplish
the task in front of you you might be a
great programmer but no one will sign up
for the app you built if you can't
figure out how to promote it so you
might need to learn how to write
compelling blog posts or run digital ads
in order to start growing when i started
my first company i wasn't a very good
programmer i was able to throw together
basic prototypes but i didn't have much
experience actually growing a digital
product so i spent months coding and
eventually got to a point where i was
pretty comfortable with python now i'm
still not an expert but i know enough to
be dangerous and that helps me manage
engineers effectively my second time
through y combinator was a little
different a few months before i started
yc i was managing a large team at my
previous company and had lots of support
my day-to-day was mostly management and
i really wasn't in that builder mindset
anymore the first company had scaled to
over 50 employees and it didn't make
sense for me to spend time writing code
when i had a whole team of talented
developers who were way better than me
as soon as yc started i really focused
on shifting back into build mode since i
was comfortable programming i spent time
learning more about marketing and
branding i figured out how to produce
video content which is really valuable
when you're selling products online and
it also led to this youtube channel you
shouldn't be afraid to learn new things
when you're working at a startup you're
not going to be an expert but learning
about a particular discipline will help
immensely when you eventually start
hiring and all of this will be a lot
easier if you follow lesson three avoid
distractions starting a company is a
full-time endeavor in some cases you can
get started while still working in 9 to
5 or finishing college but once you
start taking your startup seriously
you'll quickly realize the value of
focus when i went through y combinator
moving to the bay area was a requirement
and one that i really benefited from i
was completely broke which meant living
in a fun part of san francisco was off
the table i wound up moving into a
rundown house in sunnyvale which isn't
exactly a nightlife hub that was a huge
benefit though with no distractions i
was able to focus entirely on learning
new things writing code and testing
startup ideas i had tried to work from
other places but never had much success
there are always fun events happening on
college campuses and working from a
friend's house wasn't productive for me
either there's a lot of discussion about
burnout in the tech world but i don't
think burnout really applies to the very
early days of a startup if you're
working on a big idea that you're really
passionate about you shouldn't burn out
when i started my first company i spent
plenty of late nights programming but it
didn't feel like work to me i really
enjoyed the process of learning and
building new things that i thought of
now this is all a lot harder if you're
completely alone which is why
co-founders are so important and lesson
number four is to really focus on
building relationships with your
co-founders the experience of building a
startup is very unique and it can be
hard to relate to if you haven't done it
before this is why entrepreneurs love to
work with venture capitalists who have
actually started companies before and
having a team around you that feels the
same way about avoiding distractions and
just building is so important but you
don't need to be spending every waking
hour in front of a computer getting to
know your co-founders on a deeper level
is one of the most productive things
that you can do ideally you'll already
have experience working with your
co-founders when you start your company
but it doesn't matter if you've known
each other for years or just a few
months you can always build a stronger
relationship understanding what really
motivates a person is vital to any good
working relationship and motivation is a
complex and emergent property oftentimes
what drives a person to build a startup
could trace back to their childhood or
upbringing and you usually don't get to
know someone on that level around a
water cooler not every conversation has
to be a psychoanalysis but building
trust between the co-founding team will
pay dividends for years if it's done
right plus one of the amazing things
about bringing talented people together
is that their experience can
cross-pollinate one another in that
sunnyvale hacker house we had people who
had studied economics biology computer
science and electrical engineering we
had a great time just hanging out and
talking about what we each had learned
in college and trying to summarize
complex topics succinctly everyone has
different life experiences and sometimes
great things can come out of combining
disciplines taking advantage of these
unique situations requires being ready
to iterate which is lesson five we tried
dozens of startup ideas in that hacker
house and every time we iterated on our
ideas we got a little bit better it's
always tricky to know when to stay the
course versus when to change directions
but iteration doesn't always have to be
a binary choice you might have a crystal
clear vision of what your product should
look like but if your users don't love
it and you're not growing something
needs to change you can't be afraid to
iterate and course correct as needed in
2012 nothing was working for us we spent
months building our first product only
to completely flop when we launched so
we increased the pace of our iteration
the next product we launched in just
three weeks it failed again so we
decided to try and test a new idea every
single week by speeding up the pace of
our iterations we figured out what was
actually required to get feedback on new
ideas ask yourself do you need to build
the entire product before launching or
would a landing page do the trick
sometimes all you need is a blog post
describing what you're planning to build
if there is real demand for your
solution people will comment on the blog
post and encourage you to move forward
while you're iterating remember lesson
six set clear deadlines why combinator
is itself essentially one big deadline
demo day you need to get up on stage and
present your company to hundreds of
investors clear communication is a must
so you have to iron out exactly what the
problem is and how you'll solve it
you're also expected to show some
metrics and they better be up and to the
right yc has weekly dinners and meetings
with partners which should force you to
start thinking about achievable
milestones you never want to show up
with zero progress because you got
distracted even if your latest iteration
takes you in a different direction that
could still be solid progress if user
satisfaction has increased one of the
biggest benefits of y combinator is the
competition all the companies are on a
level playing field three months to
deliver the most progress possible you
should definitely have longer term goals
in mind but thinking in weekly sprints
can really help keep you focused on
what's most important and at the early
stage there are really only two things
that are important your product and your
users every week you want to be making
your product better in some tangible way
and then increasing the number of users
getting real value from your product the
real value part is really important
there are plenty of ways to gain the
stats and make it look like you're
growing when you're really not it's
vastly more important to get a few
dedicated users who really love what
you're building as opposed to adding
more and more users who are indifferent
about your product there are tons of
activities that feel like work but
actually do nothing to advance your
company at the early stage when you're
just a team of co-founders and an idea
you really need to resist the urge to
professionalize which is lesson seven
this can be really tempting because
there's a lot of social pressure to
fulfill a set of criteria for what work
looks like things like an office
business cards and fancy equipment will
all make your company look more
professional but might do nothing to
improve your product if all your friends
work at big companies they might think
you're a complete joke for spending all
day coding in a rundown hacker house
although that's obviously changed a bit
over the last year getting an office or
business cards may make you feel like
you're more of a real company but for
many startups the customer just doesn't
care about a professional company behind
the product they just want something
that works and solves their problem
pretty much every yc company is a mess
behind the scenes no one has it all
figured out from day one so don't stress
over this every successful company goes
through rough patches and has to work
through real difficult issues
entrepreneurship is never easy but
spending time and money trying to make
yourself look more professional than you
are is often a waste of time now of
course certain businesses might need
office space earlier than others or
business cards to sell into enterprises
at conferences but you really should
think about whether or not what you're
doing will have an immediate impact on
your startup and that brings me to
lesson eight you need to learn how to
synthesize advice from different sources
this one's a bit meta but you have to
develop a skill for assessing what's
actually relevant to your startup it's
not uncommon to hear an amazing story
from a unicorn founder during yc and
think that you need to apply their
strategy to your business but this can
be a mistake yc has lots of incredible
partners each with their own unique
startup experiences these experiences
obviously affect the advice that they
give and you need to figure out how to
apply new ideas to your business
specifically no one will ever know your
startup as well as you do so you
shouldn't be afraid to discount a
certain lesson about startups if you
think it just doesn't apply now startup
advice comes in many forms some is
extremely high level and battle tested
throughout decades this is advice like
build something people want or pursue a
big market those recommendations are
pretty hard to argue with since they're
so universal it would be very odd to try
and build a startup based on the idea of
building something that people don't
want but hey i guess nothing's
impossible where you want to be more
discerning is when it comes to tactical
startup advice like go to market
strategy the best way to launch a new
startup is constantly evolving so
recommendations like create a high
production value video don't last too
long as soon as a specific growth
strategy becomes widely known it usually
stops working once every startup is
making launch videos they lose their
effectiveness yc can be a bit like
drinking from the fire hose you're
getting a constant torrent of feedback
about what you're building and that can
be intense at times if you're not doing
well you'll know it that's why this last
lesson is so important enjoy yourself
startups are a long journey dustin
moskovitz who co-founded facebook was
once asked what it was like to be part
of an overnight success like facebook i
still love his answer he said if by
overnight success you mean staying up
and coding all night every night for six
years straight then it felt quite tiring
and stressful no matter how fast your
company is growing there will always be
a ton of work to do in fact oftentimes
the faster you grow the more work you'll
have there are always growing pains to
work through and you'll be constantly
inundated with challenges that's why
it's so important to try and find a
problem that you really love working on
and i'm not just talking about the
mission my first company was in the
education technology space and i thought
the idea of helping people learn would
be extremely energizing the goal was
exciting but the day-to-day of trying to
sell products to schools was completely
unsatisfying to me in order to be able
to stay motivated for years you need to
love the mission the industry and the
day-to-day this means you should never
chase trends even if you see a certain
type of company getting funded every
month you shouldn't even think about
starting a company in that industry
unless you're really passionate about
the space and could see yourself really
thriving in that environment for years
if you want to chat about yc just leave
a comment below or dm me on twitter and
please check out this recommended video
the youtube algorithm thinks that you'll
really like it